good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about the why and the how
of improving your fitness I love it I
enjoy I enjoy the discipline of it for
me
working on on your body is the beginning
of everything you know your mind starts
to work better you're the better husband
a better father a better friend and life
is just better when you you know care
for your body at the highest level I
think you don't invest in your health
everything else goes upon your body and
your family's bodies come first and I
want you great sure that I look after
them every everything else can plummet
and you know if you're feeling you're
feeling great and you're healthy most
likely you can get two or three extras
productive working days so yeah so kind
of find a fun way of getting healthy you
know I play tennis every morning and
every evening that cait's I do always
are getting healthy and if I happen to
be stuck in a city luckily we've got
version active gyms so I'll go to this I
think all of us work out a good amount
more or less I think that for me it's
like it's a big stress reliever I love
to go for a run I love to do yoga
it's my one hour of the day where I can
just like quiet my mind my life is
really crazy and to have that routine
every day where I do an hour of
something saying is
so what are some of your favorite
workouts or tips that you have for
staying in shape in the summer for me
it's really the it's really the running
I run for half an hour and I den I do
yoga having that time where I in my mind
and reduce stress that's has the biggest
effect on my body when you exercise
regularly there are certain habits that
you have to establish in order to be
able to exercise regularly because when
you look around
most people don't exercise regularly
they aren't in great shape you look at
them and they'll go five days a week on
one week and the next week they go three
days a week and then they go five and
they'll go to and it's just inconsistent
or they'll try one workout and then it
doesn't work no try something else or
try something else don't try something
else and you look at their body and they
don't ever get the results they want
it's because the habits that's needed
for somebody to be able to consistently
workout and get the results that they
want those habits that they establish
are the same habits that's needed for
you to do well that work for you to do
well at school and other parts of your
personal life so working out actually
helps you with other parts of your life
so next time when you're thinking about
skipping working out because you got too
much things going on work think about
this way working out is gonna help you
do better at work working out is gonna
help you make more money if you watch
that footage the thing that she does is
she falls directly on her left hip and
at the age of 56 you know it's certainly
an age where people can start to be
developing some osteopenia and so for
her it's a sign that she's living well
that she could bounce right back up
because you can't bounce right back up
if you have a fractured leg and and you
know it's not just your muscular
strength and your bone strength but your
flexibility and she obviously has
everything in her favor because
otherwise she could have been seriously
injured that is a lesson and especially
in this winter where there's a lot of
snow and ice outside people slip on ice
and what will determine whether they get
a debilitating injury or not a lot of
times is their physical fitness going
into that fall
that's why we talk about when you're
when you're exercising doing resistance
type work Madonna's notorious for her
glute work which clearly comes in handy
in a fall like that you know you're not
just doing it in fact you really
shouldn't be doing it for aesthetics the
aesthetics is just a side benefit it's
really the fact that you are not only
improving how you move but how you move
during an accident or a fall like that
when you set out to do something you
usually have a plan and if you don't
have a plan
get a plan either get my reloaded
program or somebody else's program or
make your own program but basically it's
a step-by-step what you need to do day
in and day out to reach your goal it's
very first thing if you don't have a
structured plan get one the second thing
is you've got to execute every step of
that plan along the way and while you're
doing that emotions feelings
distractions are going to approach you
that's just normal and natural but what
we've got to do is with emotions like
boredom because this is essentially what
you're dealing with get in the way we've
got to completely ignore it by turning
our brain off and doing what we have to
do whether we feel like it or not like a
frickin robot my dad used to say that
you said you get up in the morning and
you work like a robot don't think about
it that would emotionalize it and even
if you do get a feeling just recognize
the feeling say [ __ ] it and keep on
going
so you may be right now you're attached
to it you don't like the way you're
feeling about weight training it doesn't
matter what you feel like yeah you feel
you have a plan right
you don't have to play get a plan like I
said execute your goddamn plan on a
daily dictated a basis that's it
shut your brain off the body is very
important but the mind is more important
than the body you have to visualize what
that body ought to look like in order to
make it win because that's what creates
them the will the will that you need to
go to the gym everyday the will that
makes you go into the fourth strips the
will that makes you go beyond then you
do the five hundred-pound
reps in the squats and you can't do
another rep and your body is shaking
it's the will that makes you go one more
time down and struggle up one more time
and so it's all of this so the mental
aspect that motivates you and that makes
the difference between you being in the
gym full of joy and looking forward to
doing that extra rep and looking forward
to doing those extra hundred reps in the
sit ups and
can pass the pain barriers that always
the mind it's not the body so this is
why I think the body is very important
but the mind is more important than the
body a general healthy diet consists of
fruits of vegetables variety of fruits
and vegetables watching your fat lean
protein but also incorporating exercise
as well as a healthy diet
most of the population should consume
between five to eight fruits and
vegetables a day that sometimes can be a
little scary when you hear the number-8
vegetables a day but you do need to look
at those serving sizes for example most
bananas in a grocery store is actually
two servings apples more than likely are
one and a half to two servings so
typically we as consumers are eating
more than we really realize eating more
fruits and vegetables than you may
realize with portion control is actually
a good thing would be a negative thing
with certain high-fat foods high
carbohydrates that we're eating two cups
worth when we may need only a half a cup
some tips to start and maintain a
healthy diet would be first to develop
measurable but small goals don't get
ahead of yourself also incorporate your
friends and family as a support to kind
of help go along with that diet and
maybe incorporate good eating habits one
thing that's important is eating less
processed food not eating out as often
because those portion sizes tend to be
very big make grocery list make a list
on Sunday and follow that list make a
list of recipes of your meals from
Sunday through Sunday and then use that
list at the grocery store for what you
want to purchase try a new recipe each
week recipes can be very simple eight
ingredients or less look around the
grocery store and find a new produce a
new vegetable that you may want to
incorporate is a good idea also it's
hard to be active throughout the day
because we are a society of screens
computer screens television screens and
phone screens it's how we work play and
communicate and all of this time spent
on screens is not time
being active you have to actually pursue
being active throughout the day and make
a point to do that it's important to
stay active throughout the day because
all of those little activities add up
even if it's just taking the stairs or
walking around the block you need to
counteract all of the time that you
spend sitting and being sedentary it
will help you now tomorrow next year and
especially 20 years from now
physical activity benefits you in many
ways from mental health to
cardiovascular health prevent diabetes
cancer and a myriad of problems that
will happen to you if you let yourself
stay sedentary you have to make yourself
move so how much exercise should you get
a week the u.s. Physical Activity
Guidelines say just a hundred and fifty
minutes of moderate activity or 75
minutes of vigorous activity every week
the difference between moderate activity
and vigorous activity is basically in
your breath if you're just a little out
of breath but you can still carry on a
conversation you're doing moderate
activity vigorous activity you'll fill
yourself a lot more out of breath your
heart rate will increase you'll be using
a lot more muscle groups and you'll
start sweating some examples of moderate
exercise would be taking the dog for a
walk around the block going for a easy
swim or a leisurely bike ride some
vigorous activities might include
running taking that biker at a higher
intensity higher intensity weight
training or taking some classes at your
local gym how can you fit physical
activity into your day if you sit in an
office and stare at that screen all day
long get up and move you can take a walk
to lunch you can park far away and walk
in take the stairs instead of the
elevator and when you get home
prioritize activity over screen time you
basically choose to do the activities
that you want to do so if you have time
to watch that TV show you do have time
to fit some activity into your day some
ways to stay motivated to stay active or
have your friends exercise with you and
if you can't do that hire a personal
trainer who will motivate you when you
don't feel like motivating yourself or
go to a class
the gym you'll make friends and have an
amazing time while you're at it and also
nothing is more motivating than results
whatever you do stick with it for eight
weeks and you'll keep at it
hi guys this is max tapper again for
Howcast
but what I'm going to do today is just
give you a basic gym routine right for a
lot of you new guys and beginners that
are coming to the gym that wants
something to do when you get in there
this is what I would suggest okay now
very important you need to have a
muscular component a cardio basket an
opponent stretching component okay so
the minute you come into the gym your
job will be to warm your body up jump on
a treadmill go for about 10 minutes 15
minutes feel nice and warm jump off and
now it's time to workout we're gonna
pick up a few different exercises for
our musculature let's say we start off
with a barbell chest press okay to 12
reps our second exercise will be lateral
raises for our delts like this right to
12 reps third exercise is gonna be
pull-ups or lat pull-downs right for our
back twelve reps now we're going to go
into some lunges or squats for our legs
twelve reps you would have effectively
touched every single muscle in your body
with just those four exercises all right
now the next one will become abs we'll
jump on the floor do a couple crunches
let's say we stop at 20 repetitions for
you
so now you've done one round of
everything that you need to do for your
body now I want you to go through that
same circuit four times and you'll be
done with all the muscular work that you
actually need all right now another
component as we talked about before V
cardio now the cardio component I would
actually have you do at least three to
four days of 30 to 45 minutes of
cardiovascular workout to make sure your
heart is strong you're also burning a
lot of calories and your cardiovascular
system is in tip-top shape alright guys
so get out there find out that little
circuit I just mentioned make sure
you're getting your cardiovascular
workouts in and also before you leave
make sure you stretch it's very very
important
if you want to continue to improve your
fitness here are five valuable videos
that will help you take action thank you
guys so much for watching I made this
video because a Ventura tip I hope I
pronounced that properly ask me too so
if you have requests that you want me to
make for the next version of the leave
light leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of the
points you found most inspiring and
interesting leave it in the comments
below and I will join in the discussion
thank you guys so much for watching
have an amazing day between to believe
and I'll see you soon